First things first, you need fresh water and it needs to be boiling.
But just before the kettle boils, warm the pot.
You see, it's all about having the very best conditions for your tea.
And since temperature is all important, don't let a chilly pot scupper you.
Once emptied, put your tea in the pot.
It may sound daft but if you're making a normal black tea like this,...
...make sure the water is boiling when it hits the tea.
Let the tea sit for between three and five minutes.
We think the flavor peaks once it got down to around 60 degrees.
For what it's worth, we like it with a little milk added up to it...
...and we don't think it needs sugar.
Whichever way, perfect.